dès mardi les produits considérés comme
non essentiels ne seront plus
accessibles
si plusieurs commerçants ont déjà fermé
au début du confinement
c'est le tour des grandes enseignes de
fermer certains de leurs rayons
notamment textiles jouets ou encore
culturels une décision annoncée par le
premier ministre jean castex ce dimanche
1er novembre pour être équitable
la mesure ne convainc pas en fait c'est
pas ça que les librairies françaises
souhaitée c'est plutôt que nous on
rouvre côte d'ivoire est indépendante on
roule parce qu'on est tout à fait à même
de savoir gérer un flux de personnes
dans une librairie avec des jauges avec
les barrières sanitaires
respectez donc la demande de l'héberger
française n'était pas du tout dans le
sens de il faut interdire la lecture aux
gens c'était plutôt d'accéder à notre
demande d'ouvrir la librairie
indépendante dans l'incompréhension face
à l' annonce du premier ministre jacques
creyssel délégué général de la
fédération du commerce de la
distribution avait réagi sur twitter
la seule vraie solution est de permettre
rapidement la réouverture au moins sur
rendez vous des petits commerces
nous sommes par ailleurs près magasin
par magasin et via nos sites à les aider
à développer leurs activités de click
and collect jouons plutôt hashtag
gagnant gagnant certains magasins eux
ont pu garder leurs portes ouvertes
considéré comme essentiel c'est le cas
notamment des enseignes vendant du
matériel électronique nécessaires au
télétravail
on peut avoir une urgence un appareil
qui y est une imprimante là qui nous a
lâché
oui c'est important parce que j'en ai
besoin
maintenant si darty reste ouvert avec le
petit fournisseur de matériel
électronique lui ferme
c'est un peu plus compliqué oui c'est
important pour moi aujourd'hui
maintenant il faut que focki inégalité
de traitement
si les click and collect ont été mis en
place par la plupart des commerçants ils
sont inquiets que la situation ne
profite au site de commande en ligne